uh welcome back my friends this is piers
morgan uncensored with me jeremy carl
now i've sat here we've got piers morgan
uncensored mugs we've got piers morgan
on sensor pens and next they said it's
piers pack well we're changing it's a
rebrand tonight
jezza's journals political correct how
awful was that uh political
correspondent for politics joe ava
santina and the sun's political reporter
noah hoffman welcome and before we beat
them first now this is interesting over
the weekend we learned of a sunday times
report that the prince of wales accepted
a payment of a million quid from the
family of osama bin laden the prince has
said to have accepted the money from two
of bin laden's half-brothers in 2013.
that was a couple of years after the
al-qaeda leader was killed now joining
me now to discuss this is royal
biographer tom bower tom good evening
welcome to piers morgan unsensed with me
jeremy carl how are you
good morning good evening to you
morning man
how are you welcome to the show let's
talk about this um i i will tell you
straight away tom barr i'm a royalist my
old man worked for the queen mother for
41 years and i'll start by saying my
opinion which is that he used to say to
me we will never know in this country
how amazing that woman is until she's
gone and none of the rest of them will
anything will ever be anything as good
as her now prince charles has been
questioned many times before we had a a
situation of money in in bags didn't we
harrod's bags now harvey knicks maybe
now apparently a million quid from osama
bin laden not a great look
well not from osama bin laden from his
family who had uh split off from him
some years earlier it looks very bad i
mean the problem is it's not the first
time he's been caught out and as i wrote
in my book four years ago uh he was
selling access to himself for large sum
of money for many many years for more
than 20 years and he was warned by his
own father to stop it and he didn't and
in my book i did show how it the people
who he was attracting were increasingly
what we could call colorful uh they were
controversial they were people who he
shouldn't have been with let alone
taking money from them and i just fear
that this is one more uh
nail in his coffin it says being very
very dramatic
because it's going to get worse in my
view more and more of these
stories of him taking money in
suspicious circumstances are going to
emerge
and
where do you where do you get tom where
do you get that information from that's
easy to say but you have that as
information that there are more stories
you have fact to that
absolutely because i traced his money
role back to the last century back to
the late back to the 90s when he had
employed an american called robert
higdon who then was ousted by michael
forsett and they were selling access uh
to charles for dinners lunches uh drinks
or visits to his house in scotland and
uh the people
were not they were not people who he
should be mixing with and the detail was
never always available sometimes it was
but now there's clearly a leak there's
clearly somebody who's disgruntled who's
decided to leak bit by bit
and uh the stories are not good for
prince charles um let's move to jez's
journal it's not the pack uh ava santini
thank you very much santina thank you
for joining us tonight nur as well um
prince charles his judgment being called
uh
into doubt do you understand that yeah
well i think what's more interesting is
probably the judgment of the charity
commission i mean we heard this
afternoon they're not going to be
investigating it any further now i'm
sorry that you're a royalist but that
you know the chair of the charity
commission is a political appointee he
is married to one of charles's
bridesmaids i would just say that maybe
you know conspiracy theory might
theorists might say maybe they're not
investigating to protect charles you
don't have to apologize to me about
being a royalist no i'll bring you in as
well from the sun i i don't think that
this generation past the queen i don't
think we'll ever have the same will we i
can't see it i think this country will
when the queen is no longer with us
they'll go actually no wonder all these
commonwealth countries want to leave
that they don't set themselves out
somehow like she does do you know what i
mean i do not know what you mean but i
think that is perhaps more applicable to
charles than say william and kate who
polling have shown uh quite popular with
younger generations they're sort of with
like what's woke what's acceptable for
gen zed
whereas charles you can't really say the
same but i will say on this story about
the bin ladens very interestingly i
actually went to university with osama
bin laden's niece um yeah it was amazing
a bit of a coincidence um she was very
normal and quite nauseous i'm pretty
sure she was the president of um our
university's middle east society which
was a bit funny um but and she she
changed her surname um but sometimes i
think people forget
that the family is not
the same he was a black shoe for
something they're a bit different i'm
not defending the decision in any way
all right we got we got four minutes so
very quickly tory leadership over who's
going to win it's obvious isn't it i
think it is obvious but you know i mean
rishi sunak is acting as if he's 20
points ahead in the polls and actually
you know he's kind of more potentially
maybe he's turning as well 4p here is he
really u-turned though it's such a
boring tax cut i mean we're talking
i'm sorry but i mean realistically four
pence off you know if you're earning 32k
that's gonna potentially save you seven
hundred quid realistically if your
energy bills are three thousand pounds
that's nothing isn't that isn't the
truth which for a lefty you'll
appreciate the fact if your wife's worth
750 million quid whether we like it or
not your average man and woman in the
street the length and breadth of this
country are struggling right to heat
their homes and fill their cars with
petrol right they are going to go not in
a million years right
yeah absolutely rishi sunak had to do
something liz truss's team came out
straight off the bat they said 30
billion pounds we're going to reverse
the national insurance hike this is what
we're going to do to stop filling
government coffers with working people's
money you cannot say give some blase
statement about once inflation's under
control then i'll do something it's not
going to cut it with the tory membership
and that's why we've seen rishi sunak
now come out when he's behind the front
runner he has he had to do something and
that's what he's done tom can i bring
you in very quickly we haven't got long
um rishi sunak in my opinion has not got
a chance to be in number 10 it will be
liz trust what's your take on that
i agree with you i don't think he is a
campaigner i don't think he can appeal
to uh potentially labeled labor voters i
think the wealth thing does act against
him but you know on the other hand
to say that nobody rich should be
running for office it's just crazy
because we only rich people create the
wealth that the poor people need for
hospitals and schools and everything
else so i think we should drop that but
rishi is just not going to appeal he's
not going to cut the mustard um i think
he we need experience um ladies i say
that respectfully the lionesses what did
you make here yesterday but come on this
was right up your street wasn't it i
thought i don't know why you need to put
them against each other i think you know
this is so exciting because it's the
first time that women are actually
allowed to you know play football on the
same stage that men are should have been
a long time ago though right
are you a football fan i'm a massive
football fan i'm an evertonian well
that's not really a massive football
zombies used to disappoint realistically
you know i loved playing football when i
was a kid and i was not allowed to play
football after about 12 years old i
don't know why when women hit puberty
we're not allowed to play football
anymore hopefully you know change did
you watch it
oh
my defense in my defense i'm australian
and football or soccer as we call it is
not a big thing but what i am a fan of
is girl power is women achieving
breaking barriers and doing amazing
things as they always should and i could
even as someone who knows nothing about
football i felt so excited and so happy
for what girls younger than me are going
to grow up watching i felt like it would
inspire a whole generation i genuinely
said it earlier they don't squeal when
they get tackled they just get up they
are nothing compared to men one can
argue for parity and please god that
happens i just thought it was one of
those examples right very quickly where
this country pulls together which is
really nice right and also maybe i'll
inspire men to let us play football
don't have a go at me i'm not
responsible for everything men you must
be pleased about yesterday because it
gives you more of a chance i'm really
pleased that it was finally the women
who got to beat germany fantastic
although the german press this morning
said we cheated did you read that
did did you i wasn't reading the german
pressure no no nobody should read the
two caught up in westminster chaos
westminster chaos uh listen i i i want
you back if that's all right jesus
journo is one of my journals is one of
my favorite things thank you very much
indeed ava we got on all right didn't we
fantastically i love her no thank you
very much indeed uh and that my friends
uh thank you to tom bower as well and
and thank you for your patience tonight
uh we did our best uh as i say the big
dog is away we're here for five whole
weeks